hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from uh basically round
six of ala's race to the candidates he's
now facing Serge fedoruk with the white
pieces and he's already 5-0 if he wins
this one I mean he already overtook
Wesley in the live ratings but he needs
to win this one at the sort of uh sort
of cemented uh and it's a really brutal
game the clock times are incredibly
vital for you to guys to really grasp
what happened here and at the end of
this video I will also share some uh TR
truly incredible news so stay tuned for
that so alza has the white pieces and he
opens with Pawn to E4 so this is the
move that he trusts will get him safely
into the candidates tournament uh Pawn
to C5 Knight F3 we have Pawn to E6 and
now uh striking against the Sicilian
with D4 so captures captures and now
Knight to C6 going for the tyano
variation Knight to C3 and now Queen to
C7 uh like Fisher defeated uh
tonov in the candidates matches of 1971
with a result of 6 to zero probably that
is what fiser will try to do against the
T of variation but here it transposes
into the floor variation we have Bishop
to E3 and now Pawn to A6 the transposing
back into the tan of the basto variation
A3 we have Pawn to B5 and Knight
captures on C6 but here we have a very
interesting um setup for fedoruk Queen
captures on C6 and after Bishop to E2
just Bishop to B7 so of course this is
too powerful a battery you have to do
something about it first queen to D2 uh
and now there are a couple of moves that
have been played here like Rook to C8
obviously a top move in any Sicilian
setup but here we have Queen to D6 by
fedoruk and now uh what does ala do here
one thing he definitely doesn't want to
do is trade Queens this early on uh
having the white pieces but uh there's
really not a better move here I mean you
can't really avoid the queen trade so he
just castled and of course it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so ales just castles Queen side and
um aidoru just trades Queens we have
captur captures and he goes Pawn to B4
to mess up Al's Pawn structure and also
to open up the B file to make targets
for that a pawn so captures and Bishop
captures on B4 getting his strong Bishop
into the game now creating this annoying
pin here and also D4 Pawn is now weak so
you have to defend it but first Bishop
to D4 uh going after the G7 Pawn so
Knight to F6 and only now uh the
defending with Pawn to F3 uh we have
Bishop to C6 and now Rook D back to D1
uh unpinning as this is very annoying of
course uh we have Castles by Sergey and
now Bishop to E5 trying to get um more
useful squares for the bishop at some
point the bishop to D6 might be an
interesting move uh so Rook F to C8 and
now Knight to A2 forcing the bishop to
move back we have Bishop to E7 and now
Bishop to D6 with the idea that if the
bishops get traded off uh the pawn here
will remain on D7 and before black
advances it all the way to D5 you can't
really claim that you've equalized the
position fully or you know so so you
think King to f8 and now Pawn to B3 as
there is a semiopen B file on the board
Bishop captures and D6 we have Rook
captures and now just King to E7
attacking Al's Rook here uh Rook H to D1
and now Pawn to A5 and if you look at
the clock time Sala is already down to
17 minutes and the clock uh where as um
Sergey has 37 minutes on the clock we
have King to B2 ala improves the
position of his King and now Rook to C7
uh and now we have Knight to C3 here uh
probably the first move where alza could
have played a little bit better you
should never allow Pawn to A4 and you
you should probably stop it with
something like Rook to D4 and then if
white persists at least you get the B4
Square for your knight but he allowed it
uh by going Knight to C3 and now the
immediate Pawn to A4 and just uh opening
up the a file of course would be uh the
B file would be pretty dangerous with
both of the Rooks here on the A and C
files so Bishop to C4 and now a captur
some B3 we have C captur some B3 and
Rook to B7 now Al it Isa we have to
defend the weak B3 Pawn for the rest of
the game we have Rook C back to D4 uh
and just Knight to E8 trying to get some
useful squares for this Knight if you
can get it to D6 should be very good not
right away but at some point or even to
C7 and then maybe to B5 uh but here we
have Pawn to E5 H now what does this do
it uh restricts the Knight to to go to
D6 or F6 and also it really prevents
black from executing D5 so here we have
Rook to A5 going after the pawn here and
you can't really defend it with F4
because the pawn on G2 is hanging so
Alesa defends it with Rook to E1 and now
Knight to C7 now he wants to get the
Knight into the game but by playing
Knight to C7 you weaken the G7 Pawn a
little bit and now ala feels comfortable
into playing Pawn to F4 he doesn't care
about Bishop captures and G2 because he
will get Rook G1 and Rook captures and
G7 uh so Knight to A8 still finding
better squares for the Knight we have
Bishop back to D3 and Knight to B6 the
Knight needs to be somehow included into
an attack on this um B3 Pawn either
reach the C5 square or the D4 Square uh
or have some maybe checks um if at all
possible so here we have Pawn to G4 uh
notice that you cannot play Bishop
captures on H7 although this would be a
great homage to the great Bobby fiser
who you know did win his candidates
matches with with a result of six to
zero uh trapping his own Bishop although
here it would be quite worse than what
Bobby did against py in the world CH
championship match but okay Pawn to G4
here of course he want to now start
pushing H4 F5 G5 and so on uh Knight to
D5 the Knight is becoming more powerful
by the move with have Knight day2 not
perhaps the greatest move by Al Isa but
uh he can't really afford to to trade
pieces he needs to keep some winning
chances alive Pawn to H6 now not you
don't have to worry about this or also
an advancement of the pawn to G5 so all
it is starts Pawn to H4 we have Rook B
to A7 doubling up on the a I'll
threatening to pick up the Knight and
just Bishop back to B1 nicely defending
Rook to B7 and now Bishop back to D3 uh
but fedoruk says hey I don't need a win
here I'm very happy with a draw he just
repeats Rook B to A7 and ala has to
figure out a different plan so he goes
Knight to C1 which one could argue is uh
is is a good Square for the Knight but
that's all there is I mean that that
Knight is not moving from there uh Rook
to B7 putting again pressure on the B3
pawn and now ala strikes with Pawn to F5
but strikes towards what uh Knight to B4
now putting pressure on the bishop and
Bishop back to B1 ala has to keep um all
the pieces on the board and here Bishop
to D5 would really go a long way for
black but Serge does not necessarily
want to push this for a win he's also
getting very low on time he's uh 2
minutes and 40 seconds so he just goes
Rook to D5 offers further trades ala
declines Rook to C4 and Rook D back to
B5 again preparing to put more pressure
on the B file uh Rook to F4 Now by Ala
constantly having to keep um in mind
that you know trades definitely don't go
his way and now Bishop to D5 now the two
Rooks and the Bishops are nicely aligned
with that B3 pawn and All That Remains
is to bring the Knight to attack the
pawn as well and you can't really
capture if you capture then just Bishop
captures down these pawns are
excellently defended there's really not
much you can do here so ala starts Pawn
to F6 with check we have captures
captures and now King to D6 and this is
by far the top Mo the the best move
recommended by the engine uh it doesn't
really work well for black if you go
back so here we have Pawn to G5 Al is
hoping to get some sort of a pass Pawn
here uh but the push isn't uh all that
impressive with the Rook on F4 you can't
like sacrifice a paon and create a past
H Pawn and even if you could it wouldn't
really work here so H captures H
captures now ala's only chance of
winning this is to somehow execute G6
and then Advance the past F PA to
Victory uh but of course Sergey uh sees
through that he already puts a rook on
the back rank uh Rook sorry Rook to H4
preparing to go after the F7 pawn and
now Knight to C6 uh we have Bish to C2
now preparing to defend the B3 pawn and
now even Pawn to E5 the absolute
strongest move recommended by the engine
freeing up the D6 Square for the black
king uh we have Rook to D1 now pinning
the bishop but now Knight to D4 and now
uh everything is going after that B3
pawn and alza really is out of um out of
any active ideas uh you can to really
move away from the defense of the B3
Pawn maybe try to sacrifice it and go
after some sort sort of a pawn push uh
because you're just going to get
destroyed so here ala played Rook to H3
and uh he was in this position on move
49 that they agreed to a draw Serge is
completely winning here uh but I mean
you still have to play many many good
moves um but you know once he improves
his position with something like King to
E6 he can safely capture on C2 and he
will have a a winning end game but um as
this is Al's race to the candidates uh
it didn't go all that well for him so
finishes it off with a 5 and a half out
of six and um uh Wesley now again
overtakes him in the in in the rating
list you can see that now Wesley is on
27 57.4 and ala is on 27
56.1 But Here Comes the interesting part
it's not over this this event is over
but I don't know if this is true or not
I I can check one more time on Twitter
uh just to see if um if this is really
happening
uh but no it's not yeah it seems it was
it was just a it was just a ruse uh no
um someone from the C squ podcast posted
this uh on on Twitter saying that there
will be a match tomorrow uh uh
consisting of two two players so it's
not going to be a tournament a match uh
and you know people people thought that
it was going to be alza against someone
else you know to to crack that one point
lean that Wesley had
but now I see it's not it's um something
completely different um Julio osak will
face Sergey fedoruk in a match so it
doesn't seem like um it will
be yeah I don't know people are people
are still very confused by this yeah
because F first announced that it's
going to be an eight game match but now
uh you know they say it's six so uh for
the moment it is Wesley who uh uh who
qualifies for the candidates tournament
via the rating spot so big
congratulations to Wesley and also a
very nice Christmas present for him I'm
very sure uh unless something happens uh
you know tomorrow or maybe after
Christmas which we cannot know so for
the moment it is Wesley who qualifies
for the F candidates tournament it was a
nice Push by alza I mean uh uh defeating
6-0 any six grand Masters or three grand
Masters 6 to zero you know over a course
of three two game matches is uh very
very hard and extremely unlikely and he
came this close but Sergey just you know
he had an ironclad defense there was no
way to push through this ala really had
to play suboptimal moves to get some
sort of a playable position and he did
get it but it was just really bad and
you know he decided okay let's just get
a draw here uh before this goes out of
hand so yeah uh that's the game and a
little bit of extra info about the
candidates tournaments I hope you guys
enjoyed it once again big
congratulations to Wesley for now I'm
guessing uh but yeah pretty sure that's
it I would like to thank Kenneth F
Nikola wiic Maximo eer Amilia gry Scott
and Sven fer for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day